some of the photos making news today
number three British Prime Minister
David Cameron and London Mayor Boris
Johnson carrying floral wreaths during a
ceremony at memorial for the victims of
the July seventh 2005 London bombings
can you believe today is the 10th
anniversary of the tragedy for suicide
bombers struck the public transportation
system in central London killing 52 and
injuring more than seven hundred and
seventy in simultaneous attacks it was a
terrible day mmm terrible day was also
one of the first days where you could
get news quicker through social media
yes yes yes I really remember that shift
in the news right realizing that there
were some things that you could find
online yeah that weird of more brutal
and terrifying and quicker than what was
coming out of the news outlets all right
number to Pamplona Spain you can guess
what this is revelers run with the
fighting bulls along the kaya Estafeta
during the running of jeff frozen
burgers edge is that Russ koesterich
haha they're just by I had a bull number
sweet i think i saw brendan in there
were no yeah brendan you guys have you
been denying grabber been I've never
waved a red bandana and never got oh is
that somebody getting gored they get
there was one person gorge well one
person was Gordon they get hurt right
alright well that got real that got real
serious real quick yeah I'm surprised
with anyone alright in Calgary Canada
another photograph Daniel borio was
arrested for using 120 blooms and i'll
go on chair to fly with the help of it
luniz engines with the help of his 20
employees he fill the balloons with
twelve thousand dollars worth of
purchased helium and took off his stunt
was an attempt to raise awareness about
his cleaning products company but
intense wind conditions meant the
landing didn't go exactly as planned
bori instead jumped from the chair
opening the parachute attached to his
back so he did have a parachute so does
a technically count oh good advertising
I love the world I love college right
like yeah maybe just keeps and you know
there's a finite amount of helium in the
world and some of it just disappeared
into that publicity stood twelve
thousand dollars yeah he would just keep
going up right I mean until until two
off anymore Jenna frozen burgers giving
that smile where he either has a comment
or definitely has no
no second man definitely has no comment
we didn't figure out was the name was
cleaning huh well that's the whole point
right